XIAOWEN XIN: All right.
Hi, everyone.
So my name is Xiaowen Xin, and
with me is Matt Silverlock.
And we're really
excited to be here today
to talk about migrating and
modernizing your enterprise
workloads with
Migrate for Anthos.
So I think Migrate for Anthos
is a really unique tool
on the market.
And it can transform your
entire modernization strategy.
But I'm getting ahead of myself.
So before we talk about
the what, let's first talk
about why.
Why do want to
modernize your workload?
And why do you want to run
them on GKE and Anthos?
So there are a
lot of reasons why
you might want to run your
workloads on GKE and Anthos.
First, GKE and Anthos are
built upon Kubernetes.
So you've heard a lot
about Kubernetes today.
A lot of our customers
who use Kubernetes
are telling us that they're
seeing a 10x improvement
in the speed with which they
can deploy and provision
their workloads.
In addition, our customers are
seeing much higher utilization,
leading to large double-digit
infrastructure savings.
And GKE built upon
this and provides
an easy to use
simplified management
experience with features
such as node auto-repair,
auto-upgrade, and auto-scale up.
And Anthos takes that
even further and provides
an application
modernization platform
with a single pane
of glass for managing
all of your workloads,
whether they're on-prem,
on GCP, or on other clouds.
And of course, when you run your
workloads on GKE and Anthos,
you get access to the
best of GCP security
with features such as binary
authorization and container
analysis.
And so all of these
benefits taken together
gives our customers the ability
to move faster, be more agile,
and be more competitive
in the marketplace.
And so we see a lot of
customers want to modernize.
But It's not easy
and large enterprises
have a lot of unique challenges.
We have a lot of customers that
have hundreds of applications--
in many cases, they have
thousands of applications--
that were written
over the last 10, 15
years using legacy frameworks
running on legacy operating
systems.
So what do you do with these?
It's not really practical
to rewrite all of them,
make them more cloud native, use
a microservices architecture.
So what do you do?
Now, the good news here
is you don't actually
have to rewrite all of them.
We see modernization
not as a binary problem.
It's not all or nothing.
And in fact, even though
your application is not
using a microservices
architecture,
you can still convert
them to using containers
and get a lot of
the same benefits.
So this is where Migrate
for Anthos comes in.
Migrate for Anthos
is a tool that
helps you extract your legacy
workloads from your VMs
and automatically containerize
them and run them on GKE.
The tool is fast.
It's easy to use.
And it does not require
rewriting your app.
That's a really key point.
So when you're done,
you have your workloads
running in containers.
And you can leave the management
of the infrastructure,
of the underlying
infrastructure, to us.
In effect, this reminds
me of a conversation
I had with a partner recently
who was really excited
about these features.
He told me that VM management
is actually quite error prone
and a big burden for IT.
So if you are manually patching,
manually upgrading these VMs,
then after a few months of doing
this, over your fleet of VMs,
you'll often see a
few VMs that have
errors, that run into errors.
And what that means is it
also affects the applications
that are running on top of it.
So after he learned
about Kubernetes,
or learned about
containers, he never
wanted to go back to VM
management ever again.
And so VM management is--
the elimination of
OS and VM management
is, of course, only one
of the many benefits.
A customer of ours,
DevFactory, recently
used Migrate for Anthos and they
share their experience with us.
So previously,
DevFactory was using--
they had a lot of
VMs and servers
running in a data center.
And they were seeing
less than 1% utilization.
So these VMs were running there.
They're costing money,
but they're not really
being fully used.
So DevFactory decided to
use Migrate for Anthos
to move those workloads to GKE.
And immediately, they were able
to achieve much higher resource
utilization, leading to
dramatically reduced costs.
And also, they can
leave the management
of the infrastructure
to us, so they
can reduce their IT burden.
The overall solution helped
them optimize their operations
so that they can focus
on their core business.
Well, OK.
So let's now dive a little
bit deeper into the solution
and see how it works.
At a high level, there
are three main steps.
The first step is to
identify good fit workloads.
So we'll talk about
what good fit means
in a couple of slides.
Your source films can
be on-prem, on GCP,
on other clouds, and it
can be on physical servers.
The operating system can be
any one of the major Linux
distributions.
The next step is to migrate
using Migrate for Anthos.
The entire migration can be
orchestrated directly from GKE,
will automatically
containerize your VM workloads,
and will move your
entire workload,
including your code, your
data, and your state.
So everything moves
over to a container.
And finally, the last step
is to operate and optimize.
So here, you want to
make sure that you've
set up your networking rules,
firewall rules, access control
quotas, and alerting and so on.
And then you can enjoy
the benefits of a managed
infrastructure, including
increased utilization,
elimination of OS managements,
integrated logging
and monitoring, and of
course, the entire stack
is supported and
managed by Google.
Let's all dive into
that second step, that
migrate step, a little
bit more to see how we're
transforming your workload.
So if you take your
original VM, there
are a lot of things
that are inside there.
You have your application.
It has attached storage.
You're doing your own
networking inside there.
You have your DHCP
configuration, for example.
You have operating system
services, like SHAD and DPD
and so on.
The VM is managing lifecycle
of your application.
It does its own logging, and you
have your own OS kernel drivers
all within that VM.
So when we perform
that transformation,
we put that into what we
call a system container.
And you can see, at this
point, a lot of the components
in your original VM
have now been replaced
and are now managed
by Kubernetes.
So your storage is now
provided by persistent volumes
within Kubernetes.
Networking is now also
managed by Kubernetes,
so you don't need your
own DHCP configuration.
And it can seamlessly integrate
with services like Istio.
Operating system services
like SHAD, some of those stay
and some of those get removed.
And that is configurable
by the user.
The application lifecycle stays
within the system container.
As far as logging, that's now
integrated with Kubernetes
and the cluster.
And so depending on your
cluster configuration,
you can have all of your logs
be sent directly to Stackdriver.
And finally, your
operating system kernel
and drivers, those are no longer
managed within your workload.
So this is what we do today.
Now, on a roadmap,
moving forward,
we have plans to break
this up even further.
So we will split
your system container
into one or more application
containers, where
each container can now be-- each
application and container can
now be managed independently
and directly by Kubernetes.
So the lifecycle management
of that container
will be managed
directly by Kubernetes.
Kubernetes will be able to
independently scale the app up
and down, independently
manage the health monitoring
for the app, and so on.
And so as you can see, as
we go through the phases,
more and more of the
infrastructure bits
that was inside your
VM are now taken out,
unbundled from your
workload, and can
be managed independently
and centrally
within the infrastructure
within Kubernetes.
So zooming back out,
a question that we
get a lot from our customers
is, what is a good fit workload?
What are sweet spot workloads?
So our solution is
actually very generic.
And so we work very
well-- it works very well
for a lot of workloads.
So common workloads
with an enterprise
like multi-tier LAMP
stacks or Java apps,
those are really good fits.
If you have low duty cycle
and bursty workloads,
those also work really well,
because once you put them
into a container, then it's
easy to oversubscribe them.
And you can very quickly
scale up and scale down.
So what's not a good
candidate workload?
So you want to make sure that
the workload will run well
within Kubernetes.
And so that means if you have
high performance or high memory
databases, that may
not be a good fit.
If you have a special
kernel or hardware needs,
like if you need a special
kernel module, that also
may not run within Kubernetes.
And finally you
want to make sure
that your licenses--
your software licenses--
allow you to run
within containers.
So if you have licenses
that are tied to hardware ID
registration, that also
may not be a good fit.
And in some of these
cases, you may instead
want to use Migrate
for Compute Engine
to move your VM from
your original cloud,
original source data
center into GCP.
So another common question
we get from customers
is, once I've migrated my VM,
my workload into the cloud,
how do I make sure that
it's well connected?
How do I make sure it's
connected to my services
that I need from on-prem?
How do I make sure that
on-prem can talk to it?
And also what if I have some
workloads that I can't yet
migrate to the cloud?
So how do I make sure
that everything can still
talk to each other?
So to tell us more
about that, I'd
like to turn it over to Matt.
Thank you.
MATT SILVERLOCK: Thank you.
So what I want to
talk about is sort
of a couple of
customer examples where
they've had these
monolithic applications.
And these cases,
actually, are sort of
before Anthos or Migrate
for Anthos came along,
so that would have saved
them a fair bit of effort.
But they've got these monoliths.
They start on-prem--
or even on the cloud,
but we'll say on-prem--
and they want to
bring them across.
And they want to start
modernizing these applications.
They want to break them down.
They want to actually
help them scale.
But that's actually really hard.
It's hard to start
breaking these things up.
And you want to do it in a
really, really low risk way.
These are running-- it's
your e-commerce platform
with billing integrated,
with cart integrated,
with webs that are front
end all integrated.
Just ripping them out ad
hoc and rebuilding them
is not normally something
that people want to do,
because it's still
part of their business.
So we look at, first,
containerizing the application.
I think that's probably one of
the most important first steps.
That is obviously
a big challenge
for some legacy applications.
But we have stuff
like, obviously,
Migrate that helps make
that easier for Linux apps.
And then the next part is
building a network foundation.
So you want a
foundation where you
can start to break this
app apart, comfortably
route traffic and users to
the broken out services,
and still make sure that
the stuff in the monolith
can still talk to those
broken out services,
that traffic can still
go to that monolith
when it's still
handling certain tasks.
In a way, again, that is
as low risk as possible,
and make sure you
initially roll back
or manage around those
changes, trace those changes,
debug those kind of issues.
And then once you
have that foundation,
you can start breaking it down
into microservices much more
comfortably.
So as a bit of an overview
of the major components,
we've got containers themselves.
We have a service mesh, which
means a lot of different things
to a lot different people.
But the idea is basically
to have your services talk
to each other in a controlled
and debuggable way.
And Serverless--
so that's the idea
that you're not running
sort of opposite a VM level
or even, in many ways,
a container level.
You're just saying,
look, I want 10 of these.
I want to scale from zero to 50.
And what we have a sort of
fits into a whole toolkit.
So you can see we have Migrate
for Anthos on the left.
We have Kubernetes itself.
We have GKE, GKE on-prem.
You have this spectrum of what
we think as the Anthos service
mesh.
So Envoy Proxy-- so if you've
ever used Nginx before,
Envoy is a super powered Nginx
with dynamic configuration
that you can use a sidecar or as
a front proxy for applications
and do traffic shaping.
Istio is a control plane.
A lot of things in Istio
is certificate management
acting as a control plane
for your Envoy proxies
by the Envoy APIs.
Traffic Director, which is
our version of the control
plane as a managed
service, since we
know that managing control
planes can be pretty hard.
We also have a load balancer,
sort of internal load balancer,
for managing traffic between
services built on Envoy.
gRPC is a communication
mechanism and Cloud Run,
which sort of goes back to
the serverless part I just
mentioned before.
So these are all the components,
and it's like, OK, great.
How do I put all these together?
How do I actually even
know where to start?
I'm not going to boil
the ocean and just do
all of this at once.
That just doesn't
make a lot of sense.
So again, we want to
containerize first,
and then we want to start to
mesh applications and build up
the service mesh so that it
iteratively and very slowly--
so we can make major
changes as we go along.
So sort of classic
model of the gap--
it's a big, probably,
existing Java code base,
lots of different modules.
You probably deploy it maybe
once, maybe three or four times
a year if you're really lucky.
But you want to actually be
able to sort of break this down.
You want teams to be able to
be independent of each other
to also avoid team
A from blowing up
the application of
team B, so having
canary controls and things like
that as well, being a rollback.
And that sits on-prem, and you
just come indirectly or maybe
fire some sort of DNS traffic
management system if you've
got a couple of data centers.
So very simple, straightforward
setup with a lot of complexity
underneath.
And what we also want to
think about is like great,
OK, let's start plugging
in these pieces.
So I have Google's network
in front of my application.
That's putting up our global
load balancer with Anycast,
with DDoS protection,
with traffic routing,
setting up an API gateway.
So this is the core
foundation where--
today there might be a really
simple case of, just forward
everything to the monolith.
But I just start thinking,
great, actually now
I can start carving up,
very easily, very carefully,
my card, my payment
system, my billing backend
with this gateway
ready, so that when
I start to break
down this monolith,
I have those controls there.
And again-- I mean,
I say this a lot--
you can roll back carefully and
measure those changes really
carefully.
And obviously, what you start to
do is you start build that out,
and you get the
cluster ready on, say,
GKE, which is going to be
your foundation for starting
to break these
applications down.
So you start to get
some experience in GKE.
You start to understand how
it abstracts virtual machines
and how it manages the
network itself as well.
So we're breaking down one
service, breaking down, say,
service A. That might be
our billing service or maybe
our cart service--
an API gateway that
processes, hey, we're
going to send a small fraction
of traffic over at a time.
And then as we're
happy with that, that's
going to take all the
load off the monolith,
and our cart service is going
to exist as a true microservice.
And the cart team is super
happy because now they're
actually able to run
things on their own.
Again, that's really good
developer experience as well.
We are shrinking this
monolith bit by bit.
So now we have service
B. That might just
be our web front end.
So that serves as sort
of our user facing pages.
We've brought that across
now-- again, same process.
Using our load balancing
and the API gateway
we can make that a very
measured and careful change.
And now we're able to rely
on Kubernetes and GKE,
specifically, to do
auto-scaling of those services
now that we've broken them out.
We can scale them independently
of each other and independently
of the monolith that they
rely on, or we're relying on.
We can get a little fancy.
We can start to use gRPC.
Obviously, reduced
the overheads on it
so the traffic coming from our
gateway back to our services
reduces latency in many cases.
So we can start to
iteratively and carefully
bring in these additional
modernization efforts
as well as we can
break them all down.
But hey, maybe there
are some services
you do want to keep on-prem.
There are services and, as
others have discussed before,
regulatory reasons.
Maybe complexity reasons.
Maybe there are just truly a lot
of dependencies that are there.
Maybe there's specific
hardware requirements
that we can't get in the
cloud maybe just today
or existing investments
you want to leverage.
You're like, you know what?
I'm going to break
out service C,
but I'm going to run it on-prem.
And GKE on-prem is for Anthos.
Keep that there.
But hey, how does it talk
to the other micro-services?
How does it discover
those things?
So what we can start
to build in is using,
sort of, our Envoy Proxies.
This is the first step
towards our service mesh.
So in many ways, if you haven't
been familiar with Envoy
before, the way you'd
normally set it up is,
in a container system,
you set it as a sidecar.
So all traffic coming into that
container or those containers
as pods in Kubernetes,
it intercepts that,
is effectively sort
of a reverse and front
proxy for all traffic coming
into that application.
You can do canarying
through that.
You can have multiple
versions set up.
And you can do some stuff like
MTLS or mutual TLS as well
and secure and
authenticate traffic
going between these services so
that service B and C can talk
to each other, but
B should not talk
to, say, A, if we had
an Envoy there as well.
Starts to build out
a little bit more.
So what we might have is
we have a control point.
So that's the service mesh
CP that you can see here.
We need something to
orchestrate our proxies.
Maybe initially they had
a fairly static config
that we just built
into a config map,
and we deployed it as needed.
We didn't make a lot of changes.
But we're realizing,
hey, our operators
need to be able to roll
this out, again, carefully.
They want to be able to
make changes dynamically
without actually
redeploying the application.
That can, obviously, be very
easy sometimes in Kubernetes.
But if it's a very
stateful application
with a lot of dependencies,
it's something
you want to take care of.
And you might have a control
point on-prem as well
for managing the envoys there.
So you have these two
divorced control planes that
do a lot of the same thing.
And you can probably see
where I'm going with this.
And what we wanted to get to is
what we call Traffic Director.
So today Traffic Director
works through GCP directly,
and we're building this out to
have a hybrid approach as well.
So you can have a
control plane on GCP
managing all of your service
meshes on Kubernetes.
You can have it manage
these service meshes
in other clusters,
be they on-prem,
be they on other cloud
providers as well.
That's really the dream
we're going to get to.
So you have this unified control
point that your developers
interact with.
And wherever those
clusters are living--
and I definitely
recommend having
definitely more than one
cluster for blast radius--
you can manage all
those as if they're
one large unit and making
sure that application
is on, say, platform cluster
A doing, say, your Jupyter
notebook management, something
like that, or some data science
jobs, can talk to the cluster
running maybe some batch
training jobs as well.
So you want to have that
cross-cluster communication
but with a centralized
control point as well.
And this is the
hybrid approach here.
So having this singular control
plane as much as possible
either abstracts the need to
run a control plane on-prem
or controls the on-prem control
plane so that, maybe in a worst
case scenario, if there
was a connectivity issue
between on-prem and
reaching out to the Cloud,
you have a local
control plane that's
going to continue to
operate for as long
as it needs to on its own.
So as a bit of a
recap, you can see
we've started off
with this monolith,
and we've started to break
it down piece by piece.
So we're taking this
really carefully.
We've built out our load
balancer and a gateway
as a preparation
and a foundation
for how you want to do this.
And that gives us,
again, really useful
capabilities for
canarying traffic,
for splitting traffic
out, for doing traffic
on RPS and least connections.
And based on, actually, the
load of my backend as well.
I can obviously keep going
down that path with my gateway.
I've been able to
implement gRPC to reduce
overheads and increase
security on, say,
connection to other services
that support that as well.
So I've made those
changes carefully.
Service A starts gRPC.
I've built gRPC to
serve as B. I don't
have to, again, bore the
ocean, do it all at once.
And then I've broken out the
monoliths into finally as a--
we'll say, service C here, but
it could be services C, D, E, F
on-prem.
And I've had this
universal service
that talks to all applications
and manages the proxies,
manages those sidecars for
me as much as possible.
Because, again, what
we are getting to here
is we don't want to be running
all this infrastructure that's,
in many cases, adjacent
to the business goals
we want to get to.
Like, most of you
here have managed VMs,
and now we have the cloud, which
abstracts a lot of that mostly.
And we have Kubernetes.
But Kubernetes has a
large number of APIs.
And if you want to start
configuring, say, Envoy,
go ahead and look
at Envoy Proxy.
Have a look at the config.
Have a look at how
you would manage that.
And you can imagine
a fleet of those.
You get this config group.
So control planes like
Istio, control planes that
live like Traffic
Director abstract the need
to have to do those
hands-on management.
And you can keep everything
a little bit more
centralized, particularly
from a security or ops team
perspective.
So takeaways?
Containerize first.
Definitely recommend that.
So that would be--
again, Migrate for Anthos
is a great first start.
And maybe if you have some
Windows apps or things
like that can't fit
into that today,
those are processes you
maybe iteratively break that
out yourself.
De-risk your migrations by
breaking them out piecemeal
and having a plan
for each piece,
having a plan that involves
the network so you can make
those changes quickly, again,
roll back those changes,
and critically
monitor error rates,
trace where traffic's
going, trace the performance
of your newly containerized
and broken out applications.
And leverage service meshes to
bridge on-prem with the cloud.
If you're going to be keeping
your on-prem infrastructure
or have a multi-cloud
environment as well,
you want to be leveraging
service meshes to make sure
that these things can
communicate where they should
communicate, where they don't
communicate where they should.
So you don't want a PCI
environment, for example,
communicating with a
non-PCI environment.
That's a horrible ordered scope.
Using a service mesh to prevent
that at the networking layer
can make that really easy.
You can have fire rules.
You can have a service
mesh constraints.
You can have MTLS
constraints and layer
those on to get multiple
layers of protection.